hi there steve kaufman here this is my
second video in this series
of what is my korean challenge and it's
a 90-day challenge and you are working
on different languages
uh remember to send in your questions
you can either
present you know post a question here at
youtube or we do it on twitter or on
facebook with the hashtag hashtag
linkchallenge we will select a question
from time to time and you have an
opportunity to maybe have a a 15 minute
conversation with me to answer questions
that you may have
about language
and we can do those in different
languages which reminds me
one of my viewers here at youtube
writing in russian said are you going to
do all the videos in english i thought
that was a very good question and the
answer is
you know thank you for making me think
about it no i will start doing videos in
other languages
so if you want a video in some other
language please let me know
i will certainly do one in russian
because this uh viewer asked in russian
if i get questions in spanish chinese
japanese french whatever i will try and
make videos in those languages
but it won't be today uh today i because
i hurt my shoulder playing hockey and
playing golf then i had to go to the
physiotherapist and had acupuncture and
stuff and i didn't get that much done
today
focused mostly on my kbs drama
because it is easier than the podcast
that i had transcribed
and i'm enjoying them because i
noticeably understand them better now
than i did the last time i worked on
those i'm working on them in link
i can't share these in the library
because we don't have a copyright for
them
but
i am studying them i have the audio i
have the transcript hannah very kindly
transcribed them
uh if someone is really interested i
could probably individually share them
but i can't publicly share them in our
library for copyright reasons so that's
what i'm doing today and you'll be
hearing from me tomorrow perhaps in
english perhaps in some other language
thanks for listening bye for now